okay this
is about finding the null space of a
matrix a any matrix
square or rectangular and what does that
mean
that means well
in algebra we're solving the equation a
x equals 0. so a is our matrix
x is a vector that we're looking for
and
ax is a combination of the columns of a
so we're looking for combinations of the
columns that give the zero vector
dependent columns we'll be saying so
that's the goal uh and
the new start for linear algebra that i
suggested
solves that problem for small matrices
kind of just does it for for a small
matrix but for any matrix or a big one
we need a system
so this kind of completes the idea by
giving the system which uses the
oper the
algorithm of linear algebra which is
elimination so elimination is going to
be the key
to
solving
this problem to finding the null space
so that's my picture
oh these are the i'll just mention the
three books which
uh
discuss this
uh the one on the introduction to linear
algebra is the main textbook then
the
learning from data book actually that's
where this new idea got started and the
linear algebra for everyone is
got the idea in more more completely so
i'm sort of speaking about uh a section
out of that
a third book
okay
and uh they all have websites
math.mit.edu uh
the
the addresses are there
to see more
actually i should say so these are the
key ideas of this lecture and yesterday
i looked at my
lecture from
a few years ago quite a few years ago
lecture seven in the
in the open courseware series for math
1806
uh so that was on the same topic
elimination and ax equals zero so a lot
of good stuff is there but there's a
little more to say now and that's what
this
is about today so oh okay here are key
ideas of the lecture
so the null space so now you see it in
writing the null space is all the
solutions x to a x equals zero remember
x is a vector
and elimination is the key and it keeps
the same null space
and the
matlab command is rref
of a
that's the the command that does
elimination
and
we'll
we'll see
the identity matrix we'll see a matrix f
and we will the new idea was to factor
the matrix into a column matrix c times
a row matrix r so this is really putting
all the ideas together
and we learned that
if a matrix is short and wide then
there's certainly
if we got lots of columns then some of
them will be dependent and
that means that there'll be solutions to
ax equals 0. so here we go
oh okay i'm going to start with an
example
and it's already been
elimination has already done its job
so what elimination did was to get to
that you see the identity matrix in the
first two columns one zero and zero one
so that's you can't ask for a simpler
matrix than that once we've got that we
can't
mess with it so three five four six
we're
we're stuck with with those are our
other columns so the first two columns
are independent
columns of the identity matrix are very
independent
and but then 3 4 is a combination
of those two columns right
3 4 is 3 times the first column plus 4
times the second
so there is a an x in the null space
that's one of the vectors we're after
i'll call it a special solution because
it just came especially from one column
and you see it you see it down below as
s1 so we would say if we took minus
three of the first column
minus four of the second column and then
plus one of the third column we would
have zero
ax equals zero what we're looking for
and the second
special solution would come from the
last column of the matrix
5 6 so that again that's 5 of the 1 0
column and 6 of the 0 1 column
and
if we put that together into
a special solution s2 we want minus 5 of
column 1
six of column one two plus nothing of
column three plus column four giving
zero
so
in this case
elimination has made has produced this
simple matrix r
simple because it's got the identity
there
so
can i show you one more example of r
before i begin to talk about how do we
get to our okay so here's
another r
a little different though
it's different because it's got a
row of zeros
well that that won't pose any problem
but we just have to think what to do
with it we always move zero rows to the
bottom
and there it is and it does have an
identity matrix
as as like as the first example did but
you see that
the one zero the zero one is off in
column three
the identity is in columns 1 and 3 here
and
that makes a small change
but the idea is still the same
those two columns are the independent
ones they're very simple
the 1 zero zero and zero one zero those
are
totally different directions
then
the seven zero zero is seven of the
first column
so that's spotted uh a
special solution an x that i call s1 at
the bottom line you see the minus 7 of
the first column plus 1 of the second
column produces 0.
you just look at those columns minus
seven of the first plus one of the
second everything cancels and the other
one
is going to come from the eight nine
zero column
that'll be eight and eight of the first
column and nine of the third the two
bits of the identity
so the
you see that if when we have this when
we get to this uh
row reduced row echelon form horrible
set of words but what it means is
elimination has made it as simple as it
can
can be okay i might have somebody more
to say
yeah this is summarizing what you've
just seen
so we have the simplest case where the
identity just sits there at the left
or the more general case where the
identity is mixed in with the other two
columns we can live with both
and i'm using f
for the other columns the ones the
columns that are not part of the
identity and then it has that extra zero
row okay and now uh i i want to write it
the
a key part of this
lecture is to see the result this this
matrix r in matrix
see it in matrix form instead of a bunch
of numbers
uh often
in the computing you're just the page is
full of numbers and you don't see what's
happening so
what we're looking for is the identity
matrix
and
the
the non-zero matrix f
and now
in that r zero case that second example
there's a p what what is that matrix p
doing there
well
it's a permutation matrix an exchange
matrix because
the identity in this second example is
not in columns one and two it's in one
and three so that p has to put it there
so that p is a and because p is on the
right it'll do column column it'll move
columns
and
there i wrote down what that p is that
that exchanges column two and three and
puts the identity in
the where we want it okay so that's the
the linear algebra the the the matrix
notation part oh and this is this is
here now you're seeing the
the uh
new start this c times r
so that's what
i'm suggesting that that if you give us
a give me a matrix the first thing i
would do would be to find independent
columns those would go into c
and then the matrix r would
well we've seen the matrix r and that
would tell me the combinations of those
c columns to get a
yeah you'll see it well this this
box is around all the matrix formulas so
we're we're we're sorting every matrix
into
independent columns followed by
dependent columns and then this
permutation this exchange matrix p if
they don't
really come in that order if we need a
new order so
this all this is about a equals cr the
new
well not new not completely new i'm sure
but uh
it's the
factorization of any matrix
okay and now how do we actually do it if
the matrix is big and we i need the
computer to help
well we do it by elimination
okay there's this is what elimination is
about
what can what what are we allowed to do
in elimination what we don't want to
mess up the equation ax equals zero
i'm operating on a but i'm not
creating or losing any of those
solutions
so if i subtract one row from another
row
or any multiple of one row from another
row that's the main operation of
elimination and that's obviously the
equations are still true if i take 3 of
equation 1 away from equation 2 i still
have a correct equation
and i could multiply a row by 15 or any
any non-zero number no change and i can
switch any two rows
that third one of switching rows
exchanging rows is is just to move the
zero row down to the bottom
this is the example
can you see those numbers so i'm giving
an example of a matrix that leads to
that very same r that we
worked out
so so you see what i'm doing now i'm
backing up
i know the r i want i'm i'm but i'm
given some matrix a
and and it's these elimination steps
that will lead it lead me to r
okay so you see a over on the left
so it's a full matrix eight no no
identity there
but i'm allowed to do elimination i'm
allowed to do these three steps
when i want to so what shall i do
probably at this point you've seen
elimination as much as you want to but
allow me to say it once or twice more so
i would take three of row one away from
row two
that would produce that would that three
that's in the original matrix would turn
into a 0.
so can you take 3 of 3 of that first row
that would be 3 6 33 51 i subtracted and
i get just that 0 1 4 6. so i've got a
much better second row
now i'm going to use the second row
going upwards
so i'll take 2 of that second row away
from the first row
that'll knock out the 2 that i don't
want and it'll produce the identity that
i do want
so do you see that if i take 2 of that
last row that's 0 2 8 12
when i take 0 2 8 12 away from the top
row i'm left with one and zero and three
and five are the numbers that happen to
be left okay
that's uh so really what has elimination
done
this is an important idea that i think i
never caught on to when i was learning
linear algebra elimination
has
found the inverse of this one two three
seven of this two by two matrix
because it's
started with one two three seven and has
ended with the identity
so it must have inverted that matrix
and then when it applied the it had to
apply the inverse to the second half of
the matrix and it that produced the 3 4
5 6.
so you see this is oh look i think
there's probably an example that leads
to number two
here i must have thought ahead uh so
it says
on the screen what i just said that
elimination has inverted the leading
matrix
and
then
then it's
written out this step
h equal wf
that
connects the original dependent columns
to the final dependent columns
in f 3 4 5 6.
okay
i think
elimination is just a matter of practice
and you
probably have done it
and and here's an important point about
elimination
that you don't
you could do things in different orders
i i spoke and i did them in a sort of
natural order but you could do it other
ways
but you wouldn't you wouldn't get a
different
outcome you'd get the same matrix r
well because the equations are still
true at every point the the x's the null
space of the matrix is not changing by
my
elimination steps yeah so
so let's just repeat that when you
when you
finally get
to r
when you've done the elimination and you
get to r with its identity matrix that
identity matrix in r tells you which
columns at the start were independent
so that's what we you need to have a way
to do that and now we have a way
uh when i in the other uh
opening uh talks in this series in this
series about the new start i the
matrices were nice and small
so i didn't need much of a system i
could practically wing it
but but now we need a system and and of
course if we want to
use a matlab or other
code it has to have a system so anyway
we now have a system of of
row elimination steps and we know
what it's
what it ends with it ends with an
identity matrix of the right size a
matrix f
that's the other columns
and then possibly a permutation to tell
us the order
that's that's that's elimination
okay and here's the second example
so we're moving along this is like you
got to pay attention because this is
this is all there is is two examples and
then uh put the ideas together
so here's an example of a matrix a with
well numbers as big as 97 i don't know
how i got there
okay
so it bit so
there are no zeros in the original
matrix a but elimination aims to get
zeros oh here it got zeros very quickly
because
the second row of that matrix 2
14
6
70 that's just twice the first row so
when i subtract two times the first row
from the second row i get that zero row
so i'm now one step along with a row of
zeros that's great
and uh the uh and the third row improved
too
because i took 2 of the first row away
from the third row and that gave me a 0
0 at the start and then a 3 27.
so are we okay that we're at the second
matrix now
it's not finished it's not in its
r form in its echelon form but it's a
lot closer
okay so what do we still have to do
well i look at that three
and i'm looking to get the identity
matrix so i'll divide that
sooner or later i'm going to divide that
last row by three and get one zero zero
one nine but another thing i wanna do is
clean up the first row so i subtract
that last row from the first row
you see that see i'm much closer to the
identity
so i'm now moved on to
third matrix and if you've done a lot of
these you you know what i'm doing i'm
getting
i'm working a column at a time
and and by but notice column two
i can can't do anything with
column two is a dependent column it's
seven times column one i can't improve
column two but i can improve column
three and that's what we do
divide that
divide that third that zero zero three
twenty seven by three and exchange rows
then do you see that the result is
the r0
so it's the r0 with
with the zero row
yeah so that
just to repeat
this is an a this is a matrix a that
leads through the steps of elimination
which we're like remembering to r0
so so
we're really finished with this matrix a
because this shows how to get it to r
zero
and then we've already seen with r zero
we we figured out which were the special
solutions the
the vectors in the null space
so we're good we really have done the
job and
it finally it remains to just like see a
little bit what did we do
and and what's going on with these
uh
like
these column these other two columns the
f columns that that are not the identity
and and you see what we've done is
uh well
we ended up with
sorry we started with column columns one
and three
yeah so that's our matrix c those are
the two independent columns
how do i know where where did c come
from that's because that's part of this
search
where are the independent columns
they're the ones that end up with the
identity
because the identity is a way to go the
right independent columns
so they're columns one and three of the
original matrix so you see c there 1 2 2
and 3 6 9.
then f
is the part of
r that
from the dependent column so that's the
7809
and then i'm seeing the dependent
columns
yeah you have to do this a few times but
it's we've
all the ideas now are are uh and there i
put it together
so so the idea is with a small matrix
like only three columns and maybe only
two rows we could we could uh
find c and r almost by sight but now
even where we're up to four columns and
three rows we need a method and that's
the point of this talk and and it was
also the point of lecture seven in the
original 1806 math 1806 on
opencourseware okay so we've found cnr
good good
i think it's just
congratulating ourselves from here in
these are remembering the special
solutions oh and then
why not
you remember those
that for second column was seven of the
first column so that gave that special
solution that combination to give zero
and then the other combination gave the
zero vector so we've got two special
solutions ah and here's the general
principle
yeah yeah it's it's very simple after
you after you've got this matrix down to
identity and f
then
the
solutions x should should have a minus f
i remember the minus signs that we saw
so so all i'm saying here on the first
line is that the matrix i f
times the times
minus f i gives the zero matrix of
course it does
and then
the second line is the little bit of
special trick that you have to do if
there
if you if there's a p a permutation an
exchange involved here uh when the
identity matrix is not sitting where you
want it you have to have a p to put it
there then p transpose has to come into
the
into the
solutions yeah yeah because p times p
transpose so remember about permutation
matrices linear algebra is about
learning different
special
character of different matrices and
permutations
are
just take
the identity matrix and mess around with
the with the with the rows
or mess around with the columns same
same thing and and then p transpose
unmesses it brings it back to the
identity so p times p transpose is the
identity
okay
so
uh we're just about there oh then this
is the little point i made
well it's an important point suppose i
have
five columns
and only three rows that means i've got
five unknowns
and only three equations
so there are going to be solutions to
that there are going to be solutions
other than the zero solution i can i can
always
the the zero the zero combination will
surely give zero but if i have five
unknowns five columns
in a and then i have only three
equations three rows so five greater
than three n greater than m
then there will be some
some columns in f there'll be some
non-zero solutions and these examples
show
so
take take that matrix m at the end there
you see there's a matrix with
four columns and only two rows
so i've got four vectors in the plane if
i have four vectors in the plane
there's there are combinations that give
zero
they they can complete triangles
so
uh in that case the
rank would be two so so we're
we're really
seeing this part of linear algebra
to
to simplify the matrix by elimination so
that all the main facts
uh are clear are clear yeah and i'll
just oh here's if you really want to see
it in the shorthand
i'm not necessarily pushing this
last idea but if you want to see it in a
shorthand we could
think of
the matrix as having just four blocks so
it's a two by two matrix but
unfortunately each of those
guys is a block
so w is the one in the corner that we
talked about earlier
that gets inverted so so
so if you look at the last line that w
in the corner
that end up ended up as the identity
the
second
block row the jk ended up as zeros
and the one remaining guy it tells us
the the
the combinations that we
are looking for
is this w inverse h because if i
so let me look at that equation in the
box
w h j k that's the matrix i'm starting
with
i'm going to invert w
and i know that j k is some combination
of w h so
uh when i invert w i get the first
elimination produces the first row
starting with the identity and when i
apply that to the second the jk row
those go to zero so that's what
elimination is doing
in
in a real shorthand it's taking a two by
two block matrix to that matrix r at the
end
with a zero block row and an identity
block in the upper corner
so that is
elimination
and the solution of and finding the null
space so really this completes
the job of the first topic in linear
algebra is identify
understanding these four fundamental
subspaces
the null space being one of them the
column space being another we understand
now which columns are independent
and the row space being another and
and
so we're
we're really
understanding the idea of these four
fundamental subspaces in the that go
into the big picture of linear algebra
so that's this is
completes the the first major
stage of the linear algebra course
and then what's to follow is
uh come will come eigen values
singular values applications of all
kinds least squares
good good good math
and uh thanks very much so that's my
my
summary of the
of finding the null space
good